the unbreakable country this is day 23
of our patriotic war after eight years
of the war in the east the occupiers
keep uh
burned their national
wealth
on the war in ukraine they will
destroy everything that russian society
has reached over the past 25 years and
they will return
where they begin to rise into the
into the
90s only after
hopes of millions of people to
work for the developments of their
country
so this will be the result of the war
against this will be a painful fall and
they feel that
even
even against the opium for the people
delivered by
propaganda peddlers wars are always
expensive especially
the price is high for the aggressor but
whatever happens this will not uh
resurrect our dead people it will not uh
rebuild our cities and it will not erase
the
pain in our hearts that will always
remain
i have no doubt we will build everything
will become a full member of the united
nations each representative of our
country works on that 24 7 but life will
have changed forever
because of so many hearts that have
stopped because of this war
eternal memory for all those who have
given their life for ukraine the russian
troops have
continued
pounding our peaceful communities and
and sounds
strikes and aviation bombs we try to
shoot them down as much as we can we
destroy their planes we destroy their
helicopters
accounting for the fact that we still
don't have uh adequate
anti-missile
advanced weapons
we don't have enough
fighter planes but our plane is to
defend our people our country
and we will continue everything we
can do and we will
keep reminding some western
leaders that it will be a moral reproach
to them it will make them ashamed that
ukraine hasn't received
the advanced weapons that it needs to
defend
thousands of of the lives of our people
i have
lots of
negotiations
michelle the chairman of the european
council
john johnson our great friend the agenda
is understandable of course it's the
concrete steps which will give ukraine
more
but also for the economy and for uh the
ukrainians who are now and and here are
defending europe on our land
promised to do everything she can to
expedite the process of ukraine joining
the eu the processes that normally take
years it will be shortened for our
country to weeks and months it's not
easy but we will do that we have also
agreed that we will receive a support uh
from the eu for the ukrainians who had
to leave their countries because of the
war those who are abroad and inside our
country we have also
agreed on another 300 million uh
euro
for ukraine uh on top of what has been
agreed before
will also
discuss a new sanctions against russia
so that they will feel that each missile
against our state each bomb each uh
short has a price and for the russian
budget for russian companies for russian
ambitions and for
individuals russian individuals who
represent the russian authorities and
until ukraine has peace
the sanctions against russia
have to become stronger and therefore
and for the people who propose that
that's restrictions should be
restricted not just for the country but
also for certain uh communities and the
swedish dockers refuse to service
russian ships and everybody should
follow this example all communities and
trade associations if we don't stop
russia now if we don't punish russia now
other aggressors in the world will start
other wars in other
regions on other continents everywhere
where this or that country hopes to
subjugate their neighbors we have to act
now so that
any potential aggressors can see that
wars only bring losses and no
profits so that it's necessary that all
europeans should block ports for all
russian ships that all russian
commercial ships
will be
will follow that russian that proverbial
russian military ship
should leave the russian market and
shouldn't use pr cheap
to cover up
their
money for war crimes like
ocean or nestle are doing
we have a great humanitarian corridors
in several regions
and it's very difficult to arrange a
corridor from uh mariupol to the
pakistan the occupy is doing everything
to stop a humanitarian ukrainian
humanitarian conveys to this city this
is terror we are doing everything we can
we have also rescued 35 000 people from
mariupol we continue rescue work at the
sites of the uh blown up theater
the occupiers
blew it up even though people were
hiding there
we have in total saved 130
people but
much more people are still under the
rubble and we will continue rescue work
the situation is very difficult
in hiking region the occupiers continue
trying to destroy our city of issue
i turn to people in balaclava our team
is doing everything to set up an active
humanitarian corridor to those towns and
to deliver water food and medications i
have instructed the cabinets and the
speaker of the
parliament to create such uh
format for decision so that it can
provide
all the necessary goods from abroad
such as fuel food and all the other
goods that
will
answer to the basic needs of society
this is no time for bureaucrats and
ambitious people
stop and benefit from the needs of the
people we will speed up customs
clearance of all the goods that are so
needed for ukrainians if we have to
we have to
tax those
goods
and if we have to
discipline a customers uh customs
officials then we'll do that our borders
must be open to everything that's needed
for ukrainians
i
expect
adequate
decisions until the end of today and
also the then the answer from memphis
because everybody has to work today only
for ukraine
for uh our country and people not for
their own ambitions and for bureaucracy
everything has to be focused on the
defense of ukraine i have signed the um
order to to award uh state awards to 138
and there is a list of the offices
the commander of the defense of kiev
because of his resolute actions
losses were inflicted on the enemy since
the beginning of the
defense of kiev more than 30 towns were
released
liberated
outside
major terrace
commander
he inflicted tangible losses to the
enemy and stopped
its
advance
an order for courage is awarded to
rosanna
a senior
medic she took part in in saving
the wounded from uh
marijuana thanks to her
actions
31
troops were saved
she continues working in mariupol's
glory to all our heroes